Feynman learning technique is effective
full learning something new
deepen your understanding of what you
already know
or helping you study for an exam
the first step is to pick a topic
you want to understand and start studying it.
once you know what it is
about take a piece of paper and write about it
as if you're teaching the idea to someone else
ideally write and speak at the same time
just as a teacher does it at the blackboard
this makes you realize which part you
understand and where you still have gaps
whenever you get stuck go back to study
and repeat that process until you have
explained the whole topic from start to
end
when you're done repeat the process from the beginning
but this time simplify your language or
use a graphic analogy to make a point
if your explanation ends up wordy or
confusing
you probably have not understood it well
enough so you should start again
thinking about an idea by explaining it
makes this learning method very effective
once you can explain an idea in simple
language you have deeply understood it
and will remember it for a long time
Richard Feynman was a leading
theoretical physicist who received a
Nobel Prize for his work in quantum
electrodynamics
he was notorious for asking his fellow mathematicians to explain concepts in simple language
to test their understanding
thanks for watching
also check out others Sprouts learning
techniques
as they can complement the methods explained in this video
please use the comments below to give us feedback or tell us which of the
techniques is your favorite